starting today unlv is officially a  smoke-free campus the new policy applies  to all students faculty and visitors and  it includes everything from tobacco to  marijuana e-cigarettes and even chewing  tobacco a violation would result in a  verbal or written warning the school  encourages those who want to quit  smoking to call 1-800 quit now  and unlv now joins its sister campus unr  in being smoke-free as well as three  campuses of western nevada college  meanwhile the college of southern nevada  prohibits smoking in buildings and  within a hundred feet of all entrances  exits and windows nevada state college  is also smoke-free